the big story of the day of course is
that political reshuffle going on still
going on but from what you have seen as
starting with you isabella um
net are we longer or shorter
environmental champions in in the senior
ranks of government
thank you so much for
having me um i must say i think actually
we've seen a very positive shift with
michael gove going into deal with
the housing department it's a very big
challenge for the
government right now
especially
this this autumn we have been wasting
for the heat and building
strategy for a very long time and i
think that michael is the perfect person
having seen what he did when he was
environment secretary to be able to
actually champion such a tough
issue but also make sure that there's a
strong environmental aspect throughout
that okay so thumbs up there from
isabella for michael gove to housing
what would you say dame julia
um well michael gove would would have
been the one person i would have
highlighted as being uh hopefully a
positive now the heaton building
strategy of course is a is a bay's
strategy although one would hope that uh
mhclg will have a a big input to it um
one of the things michael gove has on
his desk is of course the new planning
bill and that will be absolutely crucial
and
the the version of it that we were going
to see really didn't take environment
and sustainability into account
seriously so i think we can really hope
that michael gove and his team will get
behind that and and make sure that the
new arrangements for planning in the uk
really do deliver low carbon and
resilient um town cities and
infrastructure so a lot of both of your
hopes riding on michael go there no
pressure there mr gove what about
treasury isabella because we haven't
seen any changes there yet and of course
treasury hold the purse strings don't
they so key to getting the money to
these climate goals
yes exactly we've seen steve barkley has
been moved into the cabinet office and
he was really in charge of the spending
review briefings so the entire
environment sector has spent the last
few months writing all of their
submissions for the spending review and
for the budget hoping to get what they
want in terms of financing for new
environmental and
climate schemes so
let's hope who wherever
replaces him and this week has got a
strong environmental
agenda as we really need to see some
significance spending now in the um
spending
review but also we are waiting for the
net zero
review um which is due out of the
treasury imminently and that's going to
really be a bellwether for us
in terms of how much
responsibility and
ambition the
uk government wishes to set
ahead of cop
you've both mentioned um the heat and
building strategy we're still waiting
for it it's been long promised hasn't it
um something else i want to ask you
about is actually a policy that was put
into place and that was the green
home homes grant and there's another
scheme uh that i was mentioning there
that was actually put into place a lot
of criticism it attracted
would you say dame julia the green homes
grant was it a waste of money
uh
no and i think it was right to to um to
stop the part of it that the government
did quickly but they obviously hadn't
got um well enough prepared for which
was the
the grants to people to individuals um
wanting to install low carbon heating
and and more insulation but but i think
what's been really really disappointing
is how long well the fact that we still
don't have a replacement for it we still
do have the local authority part of it
going on um which is supporting uh local
authority homes and some um
other community kind of projects that i
think is being very successful we don't
hear very much about that that needs
more more funding going into it but we
do need a replacement for the uh the
grant to
support householders because we do need
to really tackle the emissions from
buildings emissions from buildings in
the uk are something like 25 of our our
co2 emissions they really aren't coming
down fast enough for us to meet our net
zero target so this is an absolute
priority for the government and we you
know people need help and they need to
understand what they can do and of
course at the moment replacing your
boiler is a distressed purchase if your
boiler goes
then you desperately need something
particularly if winter's coming on so
you know people need to be able to plan
and we don't know what support there's
going to be at the moment yeah and time
is ticking isn't it isabella 47 days
till cop 26. so what would you say the
government absolutely must prioritize to
credibly host that climate conference in
glasgow
yes as you say only 47 days and yet we
are very
um far off meeting our our net zero
target
however if the
government
committed to the housing and transport
policies that they have put out for
consultation right now we would be a
third of the way to where we need to be
by 2032 which is a significant
amount
um and i think in terms of
the massive delay it has been hugely
disappointing and i think it's made the
environment sector feel a little bit
nervous but of course you have to think
of alec sharma who's the president of
this summit who's been flying around the
world
negotiating with very big significant
nations trying to ensure that they will
support us in this
ambitious summit and yet we don't have
anything yet to say in terms of what we
are going to do at home yet so we need
to get all of those departments to be
working better together in in short
order